freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video ich bin hier nach wie vor zu
hause eingesperrt gemeinsam mit lara und
wir werden heute sachen bestellen die
wir noch nie gegessen haben also einfach
restaurants raussuchen das werde ich
gleich machen und dann dinge aussuchen
die ich noch nie bestellt habe küchen
aus und die ich noch nie getestet habe
und ja los geht's und das ist gar nicht
so leicht weil ihr könnt euch vorstellen
ich habe vieles gegessen und vieles
probiert über das letzte jahr und da
etwas zu finden was ganz ganz mal ist
gar nicht mehr so leicht aber ich habe
dinge gefunden zum einen eine küche die
glaube ich auch gar nicht mal so krass
weit verbreitet ist israelisches
streetfood nicht nur da gehen wir mal
drauf sehr gut bewertet hervorragend 8,8
und wir gucken mal was ist hier finance
week wir zeigen wir stellen eine
vorspeise ein hauptgericht genauso bei
unserem anderen restaurant orient und
schießt xa ja das lenkrad oder gebackene
haggui und middle east side die kling
super geile story and logistics tanke
ich einfach mal dazu peter brot so
reingehen wenig vorspeisen kurze aber
schnell heraus streetstyle gerichte
original ist wieder so ein video ich hey
kriege wenig davon verspätet mit humus
gesagt nur verschieben kartoffeln
tomaten salatgurken am bart petersilie
und also nehmen wir so wie ich da steht
die haben auch ganz viel mit humus aber
ich meine das recht vorstellen wo muss
kenne ich auch so nicht klar wer kein
verlust aber nicht und so eine
klassische erbsensuppe nehmen wir auch
mal so ein 20 eure erste bestellung
fertig und dann wird es zeit für das
zweite restaurant da gehen wir noch mal
eine übersicht ihr seht um 35 bis 45 bis
die erste bestellung ankommen wird habe
ich einst rausgesucht und zwar hier und
das ist krass das hat nämlich 94 von 10
möglichen punkten medina wer bayerische
küche was haben wir hier bonus ist ja im
ganzen orientalischen kultur raum
verbreitet das haben wir gerade eben
schon nicht bestellt aber hier haben wir
jetzt mehr games mit herzhafter
milchschafe
nordafrika der beratungstag schuh kann
hier auch also nordafrikanisch sind wir
hier und das hier tallinn und dem
teilchen zubereitet dass ich diese
ansprechen kann land wachsen und
kanalisierten bis vier metern flüchten
kastanien in herzhafter onyx los
serviert mit geröstetem sesam und man
der crazy 16 99 aber opel ist in crazy
net so mitnehmen kann sondern daraus
machen sagt packen wir uns wohnt eine
vorspeise da nehmen wir aber wer mich
kennt nicht kenne ich nehme diesen
kurier salat möhren touré mit knoblauch
barista und olivenöl crazy durch alle
sondern sache ist noch nicht gegessen
habe wir bestellen und dann sehen wir
uns gleich so unsere beiden bestellung
sind angekommen der staat mit der die
nation erst kommen ist und das ist die
von medina also die bergische küche
komme erst mal wir haben hier ein
baguette von mir nicht bestellt was
liebe ich habe und was bekommt dass man
mich gestellt und zwei helfer dazu noch
mal diesen flyer ich habe ein bisschen
nachgeschaut und die bayerische küche
also wer aber sind eine daraus und aus
afrika also nicht einem ganz sorge zum
beispiel in marokko ist aber sehr vieles
mehr die machen da die mehrheit der
bevölkerung aus und das andere was wir
bisher auf israelisch also
dementsprechend auch benachbarte oder
zum teil auch in nordafrika wir gucken
jetzt einfach mal das ist gar nicht mal
so viel hätte ich gedacht also ist ja in
den taschen das wir bestellt haben
ok go
wie das also im positiven sinne wie das
riecht lari riechmann war das nicht so
locker wirkt unser
karotten salat also wenn man sich das so
an schaut jetzt genau auf das parkett
das finde ich wirklich kurios das war so
ein paket einfach zu gereicht wird das
kostet geld das muss man sich auch
umhört 16 eur 9 also es ist schon und
nicht wenig gerade ich glaube ich weiß
wieder was es ist was hier so
weihnachtlich riecht also endlich
kastanien das lied mama wohnen auf jeden
fall mein strich zettel den wald einfach
mal hier ich probiere als allererstes
hier im stück von unserer langen haxe
also guckt mal siehst du dass du gar
keinen druck auf die feld wirklich
auseinander das ist das ist wirklich
sehr sehr nice die feld von knochen und
dazu haben wir diese soße hier eine
herzhafte honig soße direkt man mit dem
fleisch hier in die soße hinein und
probiert das auch sehr sinnvoll dass
eine vorspeise aber erst die hauptspeise
probieren
also auch wenn das ein bisschen weniger
ist das ist die härteste gleich speise
die ich jemals geliefert bekommen haben
das ist ja ein herauskommen dass sie
zwar zu liefern das gab er weiter auf
dem weg zu dir und so auch das ist ja
auch ihr stunden und so zart zu werden
das so volz und kunden herauszubringen
das ist sehr sehr ich würde schon sein
dass sie gesund das ist nicht mehr
normal was heißt das jetzt noch ein
bisschen mehr durch simulierte schon mal
passieren dass zerfällt richtig mit also
das ist schon sehr sehr kraft das hier
sind habe ich so getrocknete aprikosen
und pflaumen also ganz ganz will genau
das was ich mit diesem video heute
erreichen wollte also sachen zu
probieren dinge zu essen diese außerhalb
meiner geschmack palette sich zu bewegen
was für so ein video also ein
zweischneidiges schwert ist einerseits
ist es einfach etwas neues erleben kann
ich's halt nicht erklären weil diese
kombination so die sind so für mich so
neu dass es mir schwer fällt dann direkt
vor ort oder für guckt seht ihr dass wir
das hier sich vom knochen lösen lässt es
ist eine wirklich eine unglaubliche
qualität in dem eine gabe von zum kurier
salat hier einfach ein möhrensalat kenne
ich so in der form nicht also die kasse
zu bitten
man will ihn aber man hat gar nichts zu
kaufen das ist so wie wenn man so ein
püree
der eine schärfe sehr frisch sehr happy
das ist bestellt habe ich würde es
wieder bestellen dieser perfekte grafen
von dem verstelle mich durch komplett ab
zur nächsten tagen schon besser leben
mann ist krank eigentlich und man macht
genauso was ich verspreche aber soweit
ich mir wieder möglich ist soweit wieder
rauskam einkaufen kann als mögliche
drehe ich auch wieder videos mich selbst
koche und aufwendigere videos aber
geschaut jetzt erst mal hier rein bei
nicht nur schauen wir bestellt
israelische street christi zeug dazu
gibt's hier unseren middle east asia und
ich nehme mal so ein schließlich einfach
mal rein
ich glaube ich war ein bisschen
enttäuscht ich hatte auch in die spur
gebracht aber auch im skisport nicht
lange da bin ich der anime und das
wichtigste ist erreicht ist querschnitt
bank habe ich es mag ich nämlich nicht
funktioniert richtspruch stimmt also
dadurch dass halo mir ist und irgendwie
mozzarella oder so ist es weniger käse
irgendwie also seiner konsistenz einfach
eine geile kontrollieren das ist so ein
schöner snack wenn ich den mann war ja
schon weg weg weg kaufen können da
kommen jetzt unsere suppe seine herbst
aber die sieht besonders aus die
scheinen relativ cremig zu sein dann
müssen wir noch mal neu vermischen und
dazu haben wir dieses feature
bordcomputers
waren so
heiß auf jeden fall noch
unspektakulär und machen wir weiter mit
der nächste sache wobei es werke vieler
natürlich schlecht halten also schmeckt
nicht schlecht aber es ist einfach nicht
so aufregend wie das macht mich so froh
dass hier könnte es aber sein das ist
eines dieser snack hier dominiert die
israelische streetfood landschaft und
zwar dass wir gemeinsam mit verraten
okay wir haben eine peter wie gerade
eben diese ist gefüllt gleich mal mit
einem döner darin haben wir gegrillte
auberginen gurken würfel wir haben hier
auch frittierte kartoffel tomate
petersilie dahin und eine besonderheit
nämlich einst das ist ein zwölf stunden
lang gekocht ist das klingt tatsächlich
ein bisschen ausgefallen aber das ist
auf jeden fall eine sache die ich so
noch nie gegessen habe ich kenne den
ersten bissen
[Musik]
sourcing trifft es gut also es ist sehr
sagt ich sehr lustig ohne das ist
ungesund ist also schon ist nicht wie so
ein cheeseburger modulreihen weißt du
was den gesamten monat voll mit du musst
du weißt hier rein da trotzdem frische
dann auch mit cremigkeit durch hinter
hin das spielt sich alles in dem relativ
mehr spektrum haben auch ultra
keine probiert dann kann man plätzen
sollte es nur annähernd so gesund sein
die sich anfühlt ist ein geiler snack
auch irgendwann oder so eine sache die
man sich safe reingehen kann ich glaube
dann hattest du dich auch gut so dass
ein guter start in den tag insgesamt
mein favorit heute ziehen oder also
dieses langsam gegart vielleicht
supercross nichtsdestotrotz hat sich mal
wieder gezeigt das macht spaß neue
sachen auszuprobieren
dass er macht es auch jakobs an beide
restaurants zu verdecken bis zum
nächsten video